dann laufen wir hier ein bisschen rum
immer machen wir längeren ausflug schoki
so der kombi wieder hoch und jetzt
wieder rein und sein
danke dafür kriegt gleich neun ausflug
durch meine lieben freund und herzlich
willkommen zu einer weiteren folge
minecraft hero beziehen minecraft exit
auf dem hero server heute mal allein ich
wollte endlich mit denen aufnehmen lka
in mainz wo rede direkt mit mir ich
wollte nicht mit felix aufnehmen aber
der ist ihnen noch in der uni oder so
und er kann jetzt um 17 uhr allerdings
nicht dann schon feiern bzw schon auf
dem weg und deswegen klappt das nicht so
ganz wir wollten doch eigentlich reif
folgen aufnehmen aber das machen wir
dann irgendwann mal später auch von
mittwoch bis donnerstag im urlaub in die
folge guckte gerade wahrscheinlich sogar
während ich im urlaub bin welt kann dass
die null grad alles so ein bisschen man
kann übrigens diese blueberry es immer
essen auch wenn man gar keinen hunger
fällt mir grad auf mir wurden so viele
sachen geschrieben und zwar mit einer
goldenen feder kriegt halt keinen fall
schaden wenn ich dem inventar habe das
natürlich klar
okubo haben wir auch welche geschrieben
soll ich nicht schoki nennen weil die
man eigentlich soll ich habe den ski
getauft der sollte so heißen jockey
sowie chocobo jockey einfach jockey ich
mag den namen loki so was waren noch
ganz oft geschrieben wurde war ja dass
ich mir diese schuhe mit den goldenen
feder machen kann und dass ich dann
quasi noch diese schuhe habe und nicht
diese komischen dingsbums diese komische
feder im inventar haben muss und eine
sache tut mir auch noch geschrieben und
zwar er sollte ich mir mit mexikanischen
der rüstung machen und mit knochen de
knochen klinge allerdings habe ich
glaube ich gar nicht so viele knochen
einfach so ich hab das nicht immer
direkt zu knochenmehl gemacht wollte das
knochenmehl ich habe gar keine knochen
der felsenweg da packe ich mal ein
bisschen eisen rein hier sowie für
richtig glaubt das müsste reichen und
zwar
wer deutschland machen sich wortmann
haus weiterbauen das hab ich mir gedacht
dass ich eventuell noch so einen kleinen
wiesental was gut bei mir schon kilo
kriegt vielleicht noch dein zuhause
ich dachte dass ich das hier so ein
bisschen was ist euch eine nachricht
bekommen und zwar dachte ich dass ich in
unserem kleinen übergang machen möchte
wenn das haus hier so lange geht das ich
dann hier für einen kleinen übergangen
mache also so eine art wintergarten ober
und stimmte schon wieder
das ist so eine stürmische zeit
mittlerweile dass ich so krank so können
ich weiß nicht dass dafür reicht soll
ich allgemein mal seinen garten so ein
bisschen wenn man ein haus so ein
bisschen ein zeugen hier so rum oder
oder soll ich das einfach so herum
machen hier rum ist eigentlich sogar
sinnvoller wäre wenn man hier dann im
garten rein gehen soll
obwohl eigentlich wollte ich hier so
wintergarten mäßig warte wenn man hier
reingeht
ich glaube den eingang mache ich auch
noch mal zentral oder oder ich weiß es
nicht
oder man geht dann wirklich wenn hier
die tür es geht man auch hier weiterhin
wintergarten ja das wäre wahrscheinlich
ganz cool
dann geht man hier so weiter dann mach
ich das treppe hin ich hab da noch
treppen oder ich hab doch keine bin ich
hab kein treffen
ich habe auch nur sechs davon bereichen
66 reichen perfekt für eine treppe so
die dort nicht dann mal eben so an oder
sind sogar vier treffen das gut also
heute so ein bisschen war gibt
zurückgibt jetzt heute so ein bisschen
ruhiger die volle höhe merkt da
wahrscheinlich schon einfach nur ein
bisschen bau mäßig dann kommt hier
wintergarten mäßig hin glas bis zum
boden oder der kompetenz von glas bis
zum boden und dann ich weiß gar nicht
wie ich das machen möchte ich möchte
eigentlich so eine art abbauen und dafür
muss ich eigentlich erst mal schlafen
gehen und zwar auch aus diesem holz hier
wollte ich allgemein mein ganzes hab und
gut machen
aus diesem hellen holz ich hab gesehen
dass felix hat das mit links gemacht
aber das ist auch eine ganz andere stadt
von der relativ egal
der zoo birken gebaut aus den birken
stemmen das sieht aber kaka aus finde
ich irgendwie möchte lieber dieses
verarbeitete holz sie haben und als
baumstämme dann immer noch diese stämme
die ezb da hinten gerade sieht die dann
habe ich auch ein paar nämlich die dann
so als stützpfeiler mehr oder weniger
durch muss halt wirklich mal langsam
dann fertig werden meine heußlein damit
wir dann auch mal in dungeons gehen
können uns ein bisschen jolo action
machen können aber schon wieder im
flieger
ich brauche auf jeden fall ganz viel
goldfedern habe ich genug aber ich
brauche auf jeden fall gold habe ich mir
diese schuhe machen kann so ich habe
erst mal so viel kosten dass ich das
hier vorne abdecken kann so was ich hier
mal da irgendwie keine ahnung wo wir
durch das passiert ist und zwar brauche
ich dieses hier
und dann brauche ich auch noch dass hier
so viel es geht so oder so ich dir
nehmen was euch doch die nehmen das
sieht jedoch ganz ok aus in diesem
texture pack ja doch ich nehme das oder
sieht schon cool aus ja ich nehme das
hier so und zwar wenn da die glaswand
ist soll es quasi hier mit einem zaun
weiter gehe ich habe schon ganz klein
bisschen gedanken macht also wirklich
ein ganz klein bisschen wie weit woche
das also soll auf jeden fall die ganze
farbe auch noch mit rené die farm soll
er gar nicht mit rein was aber ich habe
die farben die kann er trotzdem
weitergeführt werden so mit den links
aber wie groß war mein garten werden
eins zwei drei vier fünf sechs sieben
gereicht das tier so erreicht das so im
garten das eigentlich nicht so geil oder
manchmal auch kommen wenn schon ein
längerer können wir uns hier mal ein
bisschen dann wollen wir das schätze ich
brauch noch erde während deren märkte
mimikry kräne
dafür brauche ich das schon vier stück
ok ich weiß gibt es reicht ja doch recht
nach und dann verbrauche ich mich
trotzdem euch blöd pen hadow sodann geht
das nämlich ach nee das geht sogar hier
weiter dachte ich stimmt das sogar so
weitergehen
auch geht es denn das leben lang weiter
müssen einfach mal irgendwann einen
kompletten berg abtragen weil es ist
echt traurig dass ich keine erde haben
so die man das material ist am meisten
gibt neben steinen habe ich am wenigsten
schillig und sahen brauche ich auch ganz
viel weil ich wollte mir dings machen
übrigens ich wollte einfach diese erde
hier ab und nicht jedes gras weil er die
zusteller wir brauchen nur noch sieht
weil ich mehr auf seine eigene farbe ein
bisschen anlegen möchte weil ich nicht
immer so von unserer stadt pharma tätig
sein möchte
sondern wir also meine eigene links vom
territorium editorial territorium
ich habe sprach viel aber nein es ist
von dj antoine rutschen es ist von am
tornescher engberding so ich das jetzt
einfach nur so
das wird natürlich nachher noch alles
angeglichen blöden rosen hier will ich
nicht haben
ich werde das regelt alles angleichen
also noch nicht rumheulen hier die hobby
architekten unter euch das wird noch
alles ganz gut so und jetzt kommt der
zaun bis wohin kommenden der zaun wieder
fehler
hier kommt erstmals ein pfeiler hin
dachte ich ein zwei drei vier
dann wollte ich nämlich hier auch ein
pfeiler hin packen
1 2 3 4
die kommen dann halt an jeder ecke so
dass ich mir das village ahaus ein
bisschen selber zurecht rütteln an
diesen fünf hoch scheiße ok dann machen
die mache ich die halle 5 2 345 bis
dahin als draufkommen scheiße das machen
also kann ich das kann ich nicht noch
kann ich ja schoki kann ich dann
irgendwie fresse füttern oder so
bekommen wir einen kleinen ausflug so
gucken uns ist immer ein bisschen an der
versucht ein bisschen wie kann so ein
bisschen fliegen sie mit seinen kleinen
flügelchen dann laufen wir ein bisschen
rum immer machen wir längeren ausflug
schoki sodann kombiniere hoch und jetzt
wieder rein zu sein
danke dafür kriegt gleich noch ein
ausflug so und zwar kommt hier dann auch
nochmal sonnen nicht muss eigentlich gar
keiner hin oder das kommt schon jetzt
überall können wir uns wenn man genug 23
wenn ich mist holen
richter keinen fall schaden wegen dem
dingsbums banks bombe drin
hier muss jetzt eigentlich keiner hin
weil das soll ja hier erstmal so weiter
gehen und zwar wieder doppelt so lange
damit dass wieder alles passt dieses
meine hand so komisch hand richte dich
ergebnisse jetzt aus jetzt ist ja wieder
normal
chivu kannst jetzt mal ganz kurzen
ausflug machen hier und zwar müssen wir
ganz kurz
ich dachte eigentlich schneller laufen
so ein bisschen hätte ich jetzt gedacht
oder kann er das nur auf eine bestimmte
entfernung dass er ein bisschen
schneller ist wir müssen jetzt bisschen
bäume fällen und zwar waren da vorne
glaube ich eine menge birken kannst du
schwimmen wo ich dachte schon er trinkt
mir so oder so die hunde sind wie
übrigens alle ertrunken das habe ich
jetzt mehrfach in den kommentaren
bestätigt bekommen da ich am voraus
aufnehme habe ich bisher nur die
kommentare unter der ersten folge mit
kev lesen können weil ich jetzt halt im
urlaub bin wenn ihr das gerade seht
hinspiel viel spaß im urlaub jetzt alle
schreibt alle viel spaß in die
kommentare
viel spaß es macht richtig spaß
was können die denn da vorne so dass ich
nicht mehr boxen pukki kommt jetzt mal
nen guten halter hier für dich brauche
schon tot oder ist noch einer der ist
robson europa knochen das gut für die
knochen klinge fällt mir doch geradezu
auf
also ich hoffe man nicht das jetzt
irgendwie dies bond oder so
durch diese sogar mir das ist ja relativ
egal wo ich den park so davon bei euch
auf jeden fall noch ein bisschen holz
die brauche ich gar nicht eigentlich nur
birkenholz dass ihr brauche ich gar
nicht eigentlich brauche ich nämlich und
ich brauche ich und ich brauche ich ein
birkenwald wäre geil hier würde ich
einfach mal anzünden oder verbrennt dann
holzt ich weiß jetzt gar nicht ich
glaube ich bin bei mir zu hause 18
ich finde ich ganz bei mir zu hause ein
paar bäume an kann auf meinem bildschirm
gespuckt aber dass noch im kuko orte
sind noch zwei chocobos org will aber
nähe ich möchte nur bei meinem schoki
bleiben und wenn wir wenn ihr wölfe seht
ihr irgendwo also hunde dann schreibt es
mir die kommentare wenn irgendwo 100
oder auch bei anderen in den aufnahmen
weil ich will meine hunde zurück er das
kann doch nicht sein dass die einfachste
weg sind und ja ich brauch locker zwei
sexy von also es könnte sein dass wir
noch ein bisschen verweilen
ich weiß nicht ich sollte nicht so immer
überziehen das hat mir die man schon
gesagt dass ich immer so 21 minuten so
werde bei mir mal so lange sachen steht
ihr seht bei mir lange sachen übrigens
bezüglich pvp alle die irgendwie schon
pvp video geguckt haben wissen ja dass
ich grundsätzlich keine besseren schuhe
anziehen weil ich einfach auf meine
goldene nike nike er mit einer nike
airmax setzte sich dann an habe und
wisst ihr was ich heute hier in der
stadt gekauft habe bezüglich goldene
airmax auf jeden fall also keine
goldenen aber dr max die sind gut die
anderen finde ich alle scheiße die
anderen weiß grau blauer himmel blau
violett schwulen pink airmax sich alle
kassen so schlichte ermek sie sind sogar
und die werden jetzt immer anziehen wenn
ich pvp macht immer wenn ich pvp mache
werde ich die anziehen weil dann wenn
ich alles rasieren hallo
ok
da ist das denken sonst könne man schwer
täters hatte sieben schaden gemacht
sieben schaden jetzt nämlich momentan
diamond sword box hier war hier nicht
auch noch irgendwie da sind drei von
diesen türmen cross club uster
nein wir gehen hab wirklich erst rein
wenn ich mein haus fertig habe weil ich
möchte erstmal unsere tolle unterschlupf
haben wo ich mich dann hinzaubern kann
übrigens auch leute dass ich mir mit
ende auge und karten und so was alles
kann ich mir einen teleportation machen
und zwar wenn ich ihn wohl fast am
verrecken dann kann ich da richtig drauf
drücken nämlich nach hause teleportiert
egal wie heftig verletzt ich bin also
ich kann mich quasi immer teleportieren
und existenzen brauchst du jetzt
reicht's beim testen der macht neuen
schaden das german geilen diamonds gut
aber was hat das walkers potthast mit
acht das orchester das den vorteil dass
wenn man damit box glaube ich bekommt
man irgendwie nie wenn man damit
verteidigt oder so bekommt man damit
dann irgendwas damit kriegt man weniger
schaden damit verteidigt ich dich noch
eben ab und danach können wir wieder
zurückgehen das war's doch dann
eigentlich ja das sind jetzt circa 26 37
50 und 64 das reicht auf jeden fall okay
sie ja nicht stirbt aus weg hier
ich weiß auch gar nicht ich mir hasen
und so was alles 10
da bin ich jetzt wahrscheinlich auf eure
kommentare angewiesen
allerdings kann ich in der nächsten
folge auch noch nicht berücksichtigen
was eigentlich ein walkie-talkie da ich
kann hier in der nächsten folge nicht
berücksichtigen bist du jockey ja du
bist schon weil ich habe da noch im
urlaub beenden und dann wahrscheinlich
von der übernächsten übrigens kommt
wahrscheinlich übermorgen also am
sonntag kommt kein hero weil man man
soll ja auch eigentlich nicht täglich
hochladen das projekt war nicht so
geplant dass man täglich hochlädt
eigentlich deswegen möchte ich auf jeden
fall nach hause einlegen weil auf einem
kanal natürlich auch noch andere sachen
am start sind wie beispielsweise wahr
oder falsch kommt am sonntag anstatt am
montag und am sonntag habe ich ja auch
abends wieder
aus dem urlaub und dann werde ich auch
wieder hier aufnehmen so dass die am
montag direkt wieder hero habt also am
sonntag erstmal eine pause weil ich auch
wahrscheinlich keine hunde haben werde
zu dem zeitpunkt und am sonntag möchte
ich einmal mit den hunden so ein
bisschen die stadt zeigen so okay du
hast ein bisschen auslauf bekommen kann
sich jetzt wieder hinstellen müssen beim
bauen zu gucken und die sonne geht
schaut es kann also 1 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 kommt jeder baum in 23 45 und
dann gehe ich mal ganz kurz noch mal
kennen kann ich noch gar nicht da mache
ich mir noch mal eben ganz kurz ein paar
scheinchen so sagt zack zack zack
jemanden kommt zurück ich glaube ich bin
jetzt seit 1920 20 stück 15 minuten ich
mache mal heute bis 18
suche mit dem bis hin zum kongo
kommunizieren kommen world so hier noch
ein paar hinzu
und dann dachte ich mir dass das hier
dann halt so weit herum läuft warte ich
zeige euch das mal ganz kurz das hier so
dass wir dann hier quasi so einen garten
haben da so drumherum geht und erwartet
ihr euch das geplant wollte ich das
überhaupt zu moment oder weil ich das
noch ein weiter bauen
ich glaub ich wollte sogar noch herum
bauen das sich hier dann irgendwie noch
was habe also hier kommen auf jeden fall
erstmal hier so ein kleiner weg hin was
sollte ich denn hier nochmal rein bauen
hier weil ich auf jeden fall irgendwas
hinbauen hier was sie hier so seht da
könnte ich ja theoretisch in zwei
breiten lagerraum reinmachen warte 1 2 1
passt nicht gut ja kommen da kommt jetzt
auch so anteilen oder leider auch so ein
ding hin habe ich da nicht auf sand
gebaut nähe
da war das hier außen aber hier außen
kann ich auch erstmal in 10 93 45
könnten wir doch immer noch um styling
tipps in die kommentare schreiben
nicht so dass wir haiti braucht sondern
dass und merkt ja keiner wenn da nichts
ist sondern so was du kannst da vorne ja
auch noch oder hier solche solche quer
teile könnte ich auch da oben hinlegen
warte ich zeige es euch ich zeig euch
männchen mal da oben können solche quer
teile hinlegen
vielleicht das mich behindert
passt ja gar nicht dann muss ich ja
gleich das ja hier hatte ich zu früh
jane in den bell ding drin muss ich
aufpassen dass ich bei 60 minuten 40
aber da ich ja mal einfach nur ein
bisschen menü war kann man bis 18 machen
nämlich auch gesagt das machen für mich
bis 18 gesagt ich weiß es nicht ich weiß
das doch auch nicht management so machen
wir bis dann liege ich da oben noch so
quer teile hin
das kann ich auch noch mal eben machen
aber ich versuchen zu zeigen auf jeden
fall ich dass meine oder soll ich das so
erstmal aus lassen dass ich da ein dings
einsätze oder wacker du kommst weg da so
ein event schon durch naja wenn schon
durch auto noch einer hin und dann noch
immerhin dann baue ich mich mal hier
wieder runter ich hoffe einfach dass das
jetzt mal gut aussieht also leute tut
mir leid das ist jetzt eine langweilige
folge ist aber muss halt auch mal sein
ja kann man so lassen eventuell könnte
ich das hier noch bis zum boden
runterziehen mit holz dann hab ich hier
nicht über dieses blöde stein mäßige
drin obwohl bis zum boden runterziehen
oder nur so ein bisschen runter ziehen
scheiße oder nur hier so liebst mir
direkt eine folge dranhängen oder da
mache ich dann auch wieder diesem alter
wenn ich hier wieder diesen rein packe
brauchst du schon nice aus muss ich nur
hier unten
oder denen da oben noch bis oben
durchziehen und dann nur dazwischen ja
ja genau so mache ich das dass ich quasi
hier so ich will nicht überziehen aber
ich will das jetzt auch eben zu ende
packen so und denen da auch so dass das
dann quasi so habe zu jeder seite her
das kann man so lassen ich bin ich der
beste bauer bauer sucht frau darf man ja
egal leute lässt euch gefallen weil ich
mich jedenfalls war ein daumen hoch
freuen wir uns beim nächsten mal
wiederkommen tipps die kommentare
schreiben hat er ein bis zum nächsten
mal und